caos destrucción e incertidumbre el
sistema frontal más Severo en Chile
desde 1993 ha generado fuertes daños a
la infraestructura del país debido a las
Fuertes lluvias y tormentas de nieve de
los últimos días miles de camiones
quedaron varados cerca de la frontera
con Argentina y los conductores hicieron
refugios improvisados mientras esperan
la reapertura
compramos los locales con nuestro propio
dinero y bueno nuestra casa los camiones
ya están saliendo por otros pasos pero
acá Yo calculo que deben haber unos 1000
las autoridades creen que en una semana
se restablecerá El Paso fronterizo con
un paisaje marcado por los terrenos
lodosos pueblos inundados y destruidos
que afecta al menos a 13.000 personas
las abundantes precipitaciones serían
consecuencia del fenómeno del niño
durante el inicio del invierno austral
se han registrado altas e inusuales
temperaturas en las cimas de los Andes
donde habitualmente cae nieve el
presidente Gabriel Boris visitó la zona
afectada e hizo anuncios
hoy anunciamos diferentes medidas Para
apoyar a las familias damnificadas a
partir de este lunes asignaremos las
primeras viviendas de emergencia
iniciaremos los primeros pagos del Bono
de recuperación y comenzaremos la
entrega de más de 4.000 millones de
pesos para pequeñas y pequeños
agricultores
el 80% de Los afectados se encuentran en
la región de maule seguida por biobío y
la región metropolitana la emergencia
agrícola fue declarada en el centro y
Norte del país por la afectación a
terrenos de cultivos y la
infraestructura
hídrica